SUMMIT.
KIM HAS NOT LEFT HIS HOTEL
YET.
GENTLEMEN, IF YOU WILL STICK
AROUND THROUGHOUT THE
EVENING, I APPRECIATE IT
WE'RE GOING TO GO DOWN TO
MARK STEYN WHO HAS BEEN
WATCHING THIS UNFOLD.
MARK, ARE YOU THERE?
>> YES, I AM, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS?
THIS IS NOT -- IF YOU HAD TO
MAKE A LIST OF PREDICTIONS
TWO YEARS AGO, THIS WOULD
NOT BE ON IT, I ASSUME.
>> NO.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES
THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
THIS IS AN UPSIDE DOWN
SUMMIT IN A WAY.
IT'S GOING TO START WITH HIM
AND KIM JUST IN THE ROOM
TOGETHER WITH NO ONE BUT
TRANSLATOR.
THAT'S REALLY THE OPPOSITE
OF THE WAY ALMOST ANY
INTERNATIONAL GATHERING
TAKES PLACE.
YOU KNOW, THE TERM SHERPAS,
MAP OUT THE SUMMIT GOING TO
BE.
WHEN 88% HAS BEEN SET IN
STONE, THEN THE LEADERS COME
IN AND BASICALLY PUT
THEIR -- ON THIS.
THIS IS COMPLETELY THE
OPPOSITE.
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO
WALK INTO THAT ROOM AND HE'S
GOING TO MAKE HIS OWN
CALCULATION AS TO WHETHER
KIM JONG UN IS THERE IN GOOD
FAITH.
AND IT'S BASICALLY GOING TO
BE THE PRESIDENT WHO CALLS
IT AND DECIDES WHETHER OR
NOT THIS PROCESS IS SINCERE
AND IT'S FOR REAL.
AND THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT
FROM THE WAY ALMOST ANY
OTHER INTERNATIONAL SUMMITRY
TAKES PLACE IN THE MODERN
WORLD.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE -- BY
THE WAY WE ARE WATCHING NOW
THE PRESIDENT'S MOTORCADE IN
SINGAPORE GOING TO THE
SUMMIT SITE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE WAY
THIS COME ABOUT?
I DON'T THINK THERE WAS
ANYONE WHO PREDICTED THIS.
AND IT CAME OUT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S KIND OF
SIGNATURE BELLICOSITY WHICH
SUPPOSEDLY GETS YOU NOTHING
BUT IN THIS CASE DID GET US
SOMETHING?
>> YEAH.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE THINGS.
YOU KNOW, THE WEAKNESS THE
WESTERN WORLD, GENERALLY, IS
THAT WHEN WE ENTER INTO
TALKS OR TALKS ABOUT TALKS,
THESE THIRD WORLD DICTATORS
ALWAYS UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
PRIORITY IS TO BE IN A ROOM,
SITTING DOWN, TALKING, AND
GETTING AN AGREEMENT.
WE WILL DO ALMOST ANYTHING
TO GET INTO A ROOM AND START
CHITCHATTING AND HAVING TEA
AND COFFEE AND COOKIES WITH
THE THIRD WORLD'S DICTATOR.
THE IRANIANS UNDERSTOOD
THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, IN THEIR
NEGOTIATIONS FOR YEARS WITH
EUROPE AND THEN WITH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS THE COMPLETE
OPPOSITE.
TRUMP'S SIGNATURE STYLE WAS
BASICALLY TO GO METAPHOR
RICKLY NUCLEAR ON THE
REGIME.
WHEN IT WAS CLEAR HE WASN'T
LIKE OBAMA AND OTHER WESTERN
LEADERS TO OR THE
LEADERS TO CR THE
LEADERS TO CARTHE
LEADERS TO CARROE
LEADERS TO CARROT OF
NEGOTIATION.
JUST WHEN KIM WAS GETTING COCKYA
JUST WHEN KIM WAS GETTING COCKYD
HE DECIDED TO START TRASHING
MIKE PENCE AND JOHN BOLTON
AND ALL THE REST OF IT AT
THAT POINT TRUMP YANKED THE
RUG OUT FROM UNDERNEATH OF
THEM.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT
STYLE.
THE HOUSE TRAINED WESTERN
LEADER IS BEHAVING AS
UNPREDICTABLY AS THE THIRD
WORLD BASKET CASE GUY.
THAT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT STYLE OF
NEGOTIATION.
>> Tucker: WHOSE MOTORCADE
WE ARE JUST WATCHING PASS BY
WE SAW IT SAN SCRIPT FOR
PEACE.
THIS IS A MAN WHO DOESN'T
LEAVE HIS COUNTRY VERY
OFTEN.
SINCE RETURNING DIPLOMA
SWITZERLAND HE HAS LEFT ONLY
A COUPLE TIMES.
ONCE TO CHINA BY ARMORED
TRAIN.
KIND OF REMARKABLE THAT HE
HAS LEFT NORTH KOREA TO COME
TO SINGAPORE FOR THIS.
WHAT DO YOU SUPPOSE HE HOPES
TO GET OUT OF IT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING WHEN
HE WAS TOURING THAT CASINO
LAST NIGHT.
HE IS ACTUALLY GETTING A
GLIMPSE OF WHAT ALMOST
EVERY -- I MEAN SINGAPORE IS
SPECTACULARLY SUCCESSFUL.
HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
G.D.P. PER CAPITA IN THE
WORLD.
IF YOU ARE AN OLD SCHOOL
IMPERIALIST LIKE ME, YOU
THINK THAT'S ALL DOWN TO
RAFFLES AND IF YOU ARE MORE
RECENT VINTAGE, YOU WOULD
THINK IT WAS LEE QUAN LU.
WHOEVER YOU GIVE CREDIT TO,
SINGAPORE IS A HUGELY
SUCCESSFUL SOCIETY.
AND SO WHEN A DICTATOR OF A
BASKET CASE OF A COUNTRY
WITH BARELY DETECTABLE
G.D.P. THAT MAKES NOTHING
THAT ANYBODY NEEDS EXCEPT
CHEAP KNOCK-OFF VIAGRA WHICH
I HOPE PERFORMS RATHER
BETTER THAN THEIR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS DO.
BUT THAT GUY IS GETTING A
GLIMPSE OF HOW MODERN
SOCIETIES WORK.
AND THE INVITATION TO HIM
REALLY IS TO SAY WELL,
OVERLOOK THE FACT THAT YOU
KILLED ALL THESE PEOPLE,
HAVE YOU STARVED ALL THESE
PEOPLE AND THE CARROT FOR
YOU IS THAT YOUR SOCIETY
COULD BE LIKE EVERY OTHER
SOCIETY IN THAT CORNER OF
THE WORLD IT COULD BE HUGELY
SUCCESSFUL AND YOU WOULD
LIVE BETTER.
EVEN DICTATORS LIVE BADFULLY
DYSFUNCTIONAL SOCIETIES.
THE ELECTRICAL SUPPLY IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL PALACE IN
PYONGYANG ISN'T MORE
RELIABLE THAN THE ELECTRICAL
SUPPLY ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
HE THINKS WHEN HE LANDS IN A
CHINESE 747 SINGAPORE DO YOU
THINK IT SHAKES HIS FAITH.
>> THIS IS THE INTERESTING
QUESTION.
I DON'T THINK THIS GUY IS A
MAD MAN AND I DON'T THINK
HER HEREDITARY DICK SHARE
THESHIP SURVIVE OVER THREE
GENERATIONS WITHOUT A SENSE
OF SELF-PRESERVATION.
THE SELF-PRESERVATION IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN ANY
IDEOLOGICAL COMMITMENT.
BASICALLY MARXISM AS KARL
MARX DEVELOPED IT IN THE
19TH CENTURY WAS SUPPOSED TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
PROLY
PRO-Y
PRO-PROLA TEAR I CAN'T
.RO-PROLA TEAR I CAN'T
.YO-PROLA TEAR I CAN'T
.YOUPROLA TEAR I CAN'T
.YOU COLA TEAR I CAN'T
.YOU CANA TEAR I CAN'T
.YOU CAN'TTEAR I CAN'T
.YOU CAN'T CAR I CAN'T
.YOU CAN'T CON I CAN'T
.YOU CAN'T CONTR CAN'T
.YOU CAN'T CONTROLAN'T
.YOU CAN'T CONTROL T'T
.YOU CAN'T CONTROL THEM IF
YOU HAVE A FREQUENT SOCIETY
IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED
TO LIVE LIVES THAT FULFILL
THEIR POTENTIAL HE IS NOT A
MARXIST IN THE SENSE OF AN
ECONOMIC 240ER
ECONOMIC D40ER
ECONOMIC DICER
ECONOMIC DICTATOR.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
WHEN HE IS LOOKING AT
SINGAPORE, THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER HE CAN MAKE THE LEAP
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO LOOK THAT
FAR.
HE CAN LOOK AT SOUTH KOREA.
BUT HE IS ACTUALLY WALKING
AROUND IN WHAT A FUNCTIONING
SOCIETY LOOKS LIKE.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS DOING
LAST NIGHT.
AND THAT FOR HIM IS A FIRST.
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM
SWITZERLAND BECAUSE IT'S
CLOSER TO HOME AND THEY DID
IT IN EVEN LESS TIME.
I THINK SINGAPORE HAS A LOT
TO DO WITH STANFORD RAFFLES
AND ALL OF THAT IF YOU
HAPPEN TO THINK IT'S ALL TO
DO WITH LEE KWAN LU.
LEE DID THAT IN LESS TIME.
HE HAS DONE IT IN WHAT IS IT
NOW 55 YEARS.
SO HE HAS ACTUALLY BUILT
THAT SOCIETY BUILT MODERN
SINGAPORE IN LESS TIME THAN
THE KIM HAS DRIVEN NORTH
KOREA.
THEY HAVE BEEN RUNNING THAT
NOW FOR AN EXTRA, WHATEVER
IT IS, 10 YEARS ON THAT.
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY DRIVEN
THAT JOINT INTO THE GROUND.
THIS IS WHAT CAN YOU DO IF
YOU ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING A
SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: FIRST THING LEE
KWAN DLU WAS OEA TO
ELIMINATE CORRUPTION.
WHICH MIGHT BE A STUMBLING
BLOCK FOR THE KIM REGIME.